please remain standing for the
invocation
let us pray Holy Father you have brought
us and safety to this day and made us to
be fit vessels for your glory we thank
you for sustaining us and strengthening
us for the works you have prepared for
us to walk in these past few months as
we enter into the final stretch of the
semester we humbly ask you to continue
to give us all of your abundant gifts
and to empower us to finish the course
we have set out to run give us all grace
across the finish line with confidence
in our work and satisfaction in our
accomplishments establish the work of
our hands O Lord and in the midst of our
own labors we pause this morning to
remember the transitory fleetingness of
our lives as we mourn with Duncan strike
our Chapel architect and his family
about the tragic loss of his daughter
Raphael yesterday grant O Lord to all
who are bereaved the spirit of faith and
courage that they may have strength to
meet the days to come with steadfastness
and patience not sorrowing as those
without hope but in thankful remembrance
of your great goodness and in the joyful
expectation of eternal life with all who
love you all of this we ask Lord through
Jesus Christ who lives and reigns with
you and the Holy Spirit forever one God
unto ages of Ages amen please join me in
the pledge
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
please remain standing for the alma
mater
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
compelling and beautiful as always thank
you good morning to all and welcome to
Fall Convocation I'd like to offer
special thanks to our organist dr. Derek
staff to the Hillsdale College Chamber
Choir and - of course - professor Jim
Holloman and to Reverend Adam Rick for
the invocation and later the benediction
let me introduce to you please the the
platform party we have with us this
morning dr. Larian president of the
college dr. Adam Carrington professor of
the year and our speaker this morning
dr. Dan Copeland dean of faculty dr.
Chris Van Orman Dean of the Natural
Sciences dr. Steven Smith Dean of
humanities dr. Paul Marino Dean of
Social Sciences dr. RJ post reto
Graduate Dean and again Ravin had him
Rick the college chaplain I know with
what bated breath the scholarship
announcements are made I don't know
whether to begin with men and women and
in the all-school or women first men
first will will abide by the protocols
of courtesy and let the ladies go before
the men however the all-school grade
point average for spring last spring was
three point three seven eight now see
what happens when I read the lady's
average I'm giving away the punchline
so the average was three point three
seven eight
the all-women's average was three point
four seven nine now if you remember even
the most rudimentary math you know
something about what the next number
must be the old men's average was three
point two seven eight so congratulations
to you all
the sorority scholarship cup goes to Pi
Beta Pi with the GPA of three point four
one five the representative please come
forward
[Applause]
the fraternity scholarship cup was
donated to charity so
that was mean I'm sorry
the fraternity scholarship cup goes to
Delta Tau Delta with the GPA of three
point three three five would have
represented him please come forward
[Applause]
Larry P Arnn is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA in
1974 from Arkansas State University
graduating with the highest distinction
he received his MA in government in 1976
and his PhD in government in 1985 from
the Claremont Graduate School he also
studied in England from 1977 to 1980
first as a research student at the
international history school of London
excuse-me School of Economics in London
and then in modern history Wurster
College Oxford University while in
England he also served as director of
research for the late Sir Martin Gilbert
the official biographer of Winston
Churchill he returned to the United
States in 1980 to become an editor for
public research syndicated and from 1985
to 2000 he served as the president of
the Claremont Institute an education and
research institution based in Southern
California while at Claremont he was the
founding chairman of the California
Civil Rights initiative which was passed
by California voters in 1996 and which
prohibited racial preferences in state
hiring Contracting and admissions dr.
Arnn is on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
Center of Claremont McKenna College the
intercollegiate Studies Institute and
the Claremont Institute he served on the
US Army War College Board of Visitors
for two years for which he earned the
Department of the Army's outstanding
civilian service medal in 2015 dr. Arnn
received the Bradley prize from the Lynn
and Harry Bradley foundation he is a
member of the American Political Science
Association the International Churchill
Society the mount Paran society the
Philadelphia society and the
philanthropy Roundtable published widely
in national newspapers and magazines and
periodicals on issues of Public Policy
history and political theory is the
author of three books the founders key
the divine and natural connection
between the Declaration and the
Constitution and what we risk by losing
it and Churchill's trial Winston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government dr. Arnn and his wife
Penelope
have four children Katie Henry Alice and
Tony and and I have to tell you as I
asked you to join me in welcoming dr.
Arnn this introduction was the short
version please welcome dr.
David a man needs no introduction and it
would be a heck of a lot better if he
didn't get one thank you
I'm a in a mood to appreciate David and
the deans right now because although I'm
not losing the services of David he's
committed his soul to me for the
remainder of my life we are making
deliberations about some changes and I'm
so aware of the good character of
everyone involved and I am grateful to
them everyone and you all of you
I see the chairman of the board bill
brought back and his wife somewhere here
where'd they go oh they're up there yeah
hi how you doing came through the snow I
don't know if you know Duncan strike but
he sparkles with intelligence he said
witty he's a very happy man he gets to
do the work he loves and of course one
of the main reasons for his happiness
has been removed and we should all pray
for him and think about him and then due
course we'll all be talking to him
and we don't really know exactly what
happened except that young woman is gone
charming and beautiful young woman about
the men since I discovered last time it
was impressed on me that they enter with
the same academic qualifications as the
women it means they have a moral problem
we're gonna have to straighten them up
and this is your penultimate senior
convocation we won't talk about you a
lot today except to say that we'll miss
you and it's good to see you here and I
look at the ones of you I know most of
you and I think that's a loss freshmen
probably won't be as good
so the college as well
revenues are strong for the year so far
and applications - it's not a time of
year when you can say very many definite
things about that we'll know a lot more
in a couple of months
the renovation expansion of Phillips
auditorium is falling behind a little
bit but rich told me that he thinks that
it can maybe get there by August when
it's scheduled and it'll be bigger and
prettier and nicer things are going
pretty well here at the college it's a
good idea to think about what the
permanent things are here because this
ceremony is about that and I'm of a mind
because of Duncan's loss and because of
the chapel taking shape next autumn
we're gonna have a capital campaign and
it's the beginning of our one hundred
and seventy fifth year and that's a
milestone that's important that's a
great thing I've been getting a lot of
college presidents coming to see me
lately I've had five this month and they
all want to find out how to make their
colleges financially function and
they're all having trouble doing that
and that said and one of them came in
loaded for bear yesterday and told me
all about the Civil War history of his
college and I was terribly impressed and
I didn't say much about ours except he
asked me he said well so you have a
Civil War history
I said we do and he said tell me about
that and I did you know helped to found
the party of Abraham Lincoln Frederick
Douglass spoke here twice founded to be
an anti-slavery college all of that you
know and on and on there's more right
how many people fought in the Battle of
Gettysburg from here all of that and I
just told him part of that and he said
oh I see
[Laughter]
but see whatever led that to happen what
caused that
that's not accidents just of that time
that happened because we love the Lord
and the study of every high thing and
the free station of the human being
placed in that part of the hierarchy of
nature we love those things and we think
we need to know those things in order to
live our lives well you know there's
more regulations being made lately and
the theme is now so so consistent that
it's laughable if it wasn't tragic what
people who make laws and rules in this
country think is they think that these
seniors here have to be trained like
factors of production they think that we
have to give them skills to adapt to the
job market in the new world well of
course they need those skills right but
what are those skills they need to think
and to know and to form their souls
according to the good and they do most
of that work themselves thank you
seniors one of the best punches I ever
saw I'm really having fun with the
officers they're corrupt but they're a
little embarrassed about it corrupt is
not the word but they do like celebrity
a little bit more than we're joshing
them about it so you see this whole
thing right our Chapel I'm gonna give if
the Lord will cooperate with me if I
will cooperate with him excuse me Father
Adam the chapel is not going to be ready
for commencement it's gonna be ready
inside I think and I'll even tell you
the reason first of all it's I give
tours now if you wanted to or sign up
and you know I don't we've built a lot
of buildings around here and I hardly
have time to go see them but I've been
to see that thing about ten times now I
have a key I don't have a key to the
bookstore but I did have one but I lost
it and they won't give me another one
but it it will make you gasp when you go
in there and why is it late well there's
a guy named Donny over there and he's
the leader of 25 Mason's who are working
on this thing for months now and they
will say I never thought I'd get to see
or do something like this and they're
grateful they all love to college if I
walk in there several of them always
come down and and want to show me things
come and see this right if you if you
look on this on one of the long sides
you'll see these brick outcroppings
where the brick is the same but it's
just standing out a bit and the top of
that every one of those is granite
capital they weigh 7500 pounds every one
of them has to be placed just right if
you look at the front door and look to
the left about about five feet higher
than the level of the door there's a
cornice which is a ledge sticking out
and they got it off by half an inch and
if you look at that thing you'll see
it's big and so they discovered that and
they called the architect and they said
we're gonna have to take that thing down
and put it back up again and and we're
running a little late on the masonry
we're calling Italy looking for Masons
and and Duncan said got to move in so we
lost a day half a day something like
that to move that thing and if you look
and Duncan comes and does this he
measures every piece of limestone that
goes in that same thing himself and
marks it and initials it it's gonna be
pretty
it's going to take our breath away and
so what I'm gonna try to do I went to
the forum and the other day and I said
you know you guys are really great and I
love you but you don't understand the
college business and they said why not
and I said well you know I've got these
seniors and they've been watching the
construction project for a long time and
you gave me news yesterday says they're
not gonna get to use it and he said oh I
didn't think of that and I said well you
know I did him said as a matter of fact
they are went to get to use it and he
said well it won't be ready and I said
yeah well and he said no and I said yeah
and he said okay so what we're gonna
have to do if we can do it and I'm not
promising but I want you to on trying is
sometime in the week before commencement
because I think the interior supposed to
be finished is P what you hear today
he's he dodged he's he's such a coward I
think what we can do is make an entrance
in the side and we can all go in and
have a church service probably with your
parents I don't know how many we can
accommodate it's a question of the fire
code and I don't know how serious we are
about that here so C thing next year
we're gonna start that thing that
hundred and seventy fifth celebration
and that is something going on all that
time and I don't know of anything else
like it people come and marvel at this
and ask how do you get this done and of
course it has enemies we talked about
that at pre-opening conference and there
are more of them as time goes on and
they will cause us trouble and we will
fight remember to pray for the college
it's a great thing and much depends on
it
Susan Lanier gave us the anonymous gift
for the in leader T teaching award
it's in a it's named after her grand
mother whom she loved and the award is
given in the fall to a junior faculty
member and in the spring to a senior
faculty member and I think Emily but
maybe Blackstock Bob Blackstock had this
idea was it you or she that we should
give some money to the department to so
they wouldn't be jealous I guess so
these are always delightful and the list
of who's wanted is in your program and
you should look down that list because
this is an award that's well chosen this
year's this semester's winner is a nerd
he's been here since 2013 he went to
Harvey Mudd College next to where I went
for graduate school I used to go up
there and read on benches that were up
there and everybody up there was an
incredible nerd this guy seems like he's
not nearly as nerdy as most of them and
he has distinguished himself he went to
Harvey Mudd College in the University
California Los Angeles UCLA and then the
University of Iowa and he's a
mathematician and his name is David
Gabler please come up
[Applause]
is Tom to Lorne here oh yeah sorry
of course he's here I'll just sign okay
so you get
you